[Music]
hey one it's me Debbie now surprise
during pregnancy it was pretty brutal
but even now that I'm breastfeeding say
no to that post Jim sugar-free apple
martini is hella rough but you know what
I always say a B if it's not complete
restriction it's not worth doing am i
right
hey Debbie I totally agree abstain from
alcohol during pregnancy was really
challenging I mean you remember that
video I did about the top foods that I
was missing during pregnancy if you
haven't watched that video yet you can
definitely check it out right here but I
don't agree that you need to completely
abstain
alcohol while breastfeeding in fact half
of the women in the Western world drink
some alcohol well nursing well you know
I'm not most women and even so when
women who are breastfeeding drink
alcohol the alcohol gets into their
breast milk and it's basically like
feeding their babe a White Russian so
the research on breastfeeding and
alcohol consumption has been a bit of a
roller coaster while some experts
suggest that a little bit of alcohol may
help stimulate milk production other
experts recommend the pump-and-dump
method which is basically where you pump
your milk out and then dump it out after
you've had a drink well now I'm like
super confused what's the truth here AB
well I think the stigma here is around
our tendency to treat drinking while
breastfeeding the same way we treat
drinking while pregnant
but these two situations are completely
different when we're pregnant alcohol
tends to go right from the mothers
bloodstream into the placenta and can
ask you quite a lot of harms the
developing fetus but when we're
breastfeeding the metabolism of alcohol
and it's transferred to our milk is
completely different like when you drink
alcohol even if it's just a little it
gets into the breast milk why would I
want to feed that toxin to my baby a
comprehensive study found that the
amount of alcohol that is suggested by a
baby to breast milk is so little it's
pretty much negligible basically the
amount of alcohol that passes on to the
breast milk
same concentration that is found in the
mother's blood so here's an example
death let's say you go out when your
daily sangria outings with your squad
and you consume four glasses of sangria
in one sitting that's a lot of booze so
let's assume that your blood alcohol
concentration is about 0.08 percent and
therefore your breast milk also contains
0.08 percent alcohol now in context a
lot of fruit juices contain 0.1% alcohol
just from fermentation but that still
means that my baby will have point zero
eight percent alcohol in their
bloodstream I don't like that actually
Deb just because your blood alcohol
concentration is 0.08 percent doesn't
necessarily mean the same thing for baby
if you were to breastfeed immediately
after the sangria session your baby's
blood alcohol concentration would likely
be closer to 0.05 percent and this
amount is likely to have little to no
impact on your baby still if I give in
to my alcohol cravings I'll only feel
comfortable if I pump and dump listen
dad you do whatever you feel comfortable
doing but just know that studies have
shown that the alcohol content your
blood Peaks around thirty to sixty
minutes after drinking meaning your body
starts to break it down and your blood
alcohol concentration will start to
decline if you're still really worried
about it rather than puffing and dumping
that liquid gold simply just wait over
an hour before you feed and trysting
well where's the research that suggests
that drinking while breastfeeding will
leave my baby unharmed
I study with over 400 women found that
over 60% of them drink alcohol while
breastfeeding
both at eight weeks and twelve months
postpartum the women had less than 14
drinks per week and they found no
association between drinking alcohol and
the babies overall health and
development
that's a promising start but what about
those rumors that actually can increase
my breast milk supply can I safely enjoy
my mojitos while actually increasing my
output not so fast
so a drink is often recommended to mamas
who need to relax a little bit more in
order to get a good pump or breastfeed
however research has actually shown that
alcohol may inhibit the role of oxytocin
which in turn may reduce breast milk
release however this was only shown in
mothers who had more than two drinks a
day so it's possible that just one drink
a day is a better guideline it's also
not very concerning if a baby has a
smaller feed at one breastfeeding
session because babies are so in tune
with their hunger and satiety cues
they'll likely make up those calories
later on in the day okay so what about
the impact on baby sleep well that glass
of pinot actually helped my baby sleep
better at night actually that may be not
one side he found that babies tended to
sleep a little bit less following the
exposure of alcohol on their mom's milk
however this tended to only last about
three and a half hours after feeding and
the babies made up that sleep in the
next 20 hours well Abby you've
definitely given me a lot to think about
when it comes to alcohol breastfeeding I
might just have to start living that
everything in moderation light so I like
I like to hear that Deb you know I think
ultimately you better do what works for
you but don't make yourself miserable
unnecessarily one thing to know is that
a lot of the studies that we cited were
really short-term and we don't have a
ton of great literature when it comes to
long-term effects of breastfeeding while
drinking the bottom line is there's
usually some wiggle room when it comes
to breastfeeding and drinking as long as
you stick to the general guidelines of
no more than two drinks a day and ten
drinks a week drinking while
breastfeeding is less about the safety
of your milk and more about the safety
of caring for your baby will honor the
influence
so if you're feeling tipsy do not pick
up your baby and never let your baby
sleep with you or on you so guys I hope
you enjoyed this video if you did be
sure to give it the thumbs up leave me
your comments below and your thoughts
about drinking about breastfeeding
subscribe to the channel and I'll see
you next time on Abby's kitchen bye